*dark choral music with intense drums*
Problem is... If you fight with an edge blade... I'll have to.
And if I fight with an edge blade... I'll have no one left to pay me.
I get away from the hustlin' crowd...
And all that rat race noise down in the street.
Send Rob Stark's head... I'm going to serve it to Sansa at my wedding feast.
It's you isn't it?
*adults fighting offscreen*
The other kids won't believe me.
Your brother is a killer...
Your sons will be killers some day...
*celtic violin*
There's oats, and there's oats... But there's only one Scott's Porage Oats.
My husband trusted you... and you repaid our faith with treachery.
I didn't ask the gods what it meant... I didn't need to.
I already knew.
Don't worry Harry we'll explain everything when we get back to headquarters.
Shhh! Not here Nymphadora.
Don't call me Nymphadora.
I wish I had enough poison for the whole pack of you. I would gladly give my life to watch you all swallow it.
Hot date last night?
I wish.
A women with a sexy voice like yours, it's hard to believe you're waking up alone.
Each wanting to grow the tallest, bloom the brightest...
And one by one sooner or later they all get plucked.
My lord, the fleet has moved out of lightspeed...
Com-Scan has detected an energy field protecting an area of the sixth planet of the Hoth system. The field is strong enough to deflect any bombardment.
Chaos isn't a pit...
Chaos is a ladder.
A sorcerer called and a voice answered. And ever since that day I have hated magic.
Go out. Out there under the sky, look around. What is the saying?
Distance lends enchantment to the viewer.
Which would have given us more time to deal with Robert's brothers, but now...
Madness... madness, and stupidity.
Or what?
Or nipple cripple... That's what!
Caved in his breastplate...
Probably shattered every rib he had.
And that's another thing... enough with the dumb-dumb
My name is Fred Flintstone. F.L.I.N... T... Stone.
Would you shut up for once in your life... I said I was sorry!
I meant it.
And that's all I gotta' say, you understand... Last time I checked we weren't married... Or even related.
So you better stop throwing your crazy guilt around, before I throw you through the damn window!